bonjour monsieur le ministre
monsieur le rapporteur mes recherches
collect merci monsieur le ministre
d'avoir répondu présent à notre
convocation à cette commission d'enquête
sur l'efficacité des politiques
publiques en matière de rénovation
énergétique demandée par le groupe
écologiste et donc nous avons débuté nos
travaux il y a maintenant presque un
petit mois et nous avons d'ores et déjà
auditionné la quasi entièreté des
ministres de la transition écologique et
ou du logement donc voilà vous achevez
en auditionnera enfin de nos travaux les
ministres qui sont en poste actuel dans
ces mêmes ministères et délégation donc
monsieur le ministre vous avez été
secrétaire d'État auprès du ministre de
la cohésion des territoires de 2017 à
2018 puis ministre délégué chargé de la
ville et du logement à partir d'octobre
2018 jusqu'en 2020 vous avez ensuite été
ministre de et de l'alimentation jusqu'à
la fin du premier quinquennat d'Emmanuel
Macron c'est bien entendu en votre
qualité d'anciens ministres chargés du
logement que nous vous recevons
aujourd'hui dans le cadre de ces
fonctions vous avez préparé et suivi
l'examen de la loi énergie climat de
2019 le volet logement de cette loi
comportait des mesures de lutte contre
la fraude au certificat d'économie
d'énergie les C2E et un plan de lutte
contre les passoires thermiques ciblées
sur la vente et la location de ses biens
vous avez également mené la refonte du
crédit d'impôt pour la transition
énergétique le cite et du dispositif
habitait mieux agit le thé pour créer ma
prime rénov
monsieur le ministre je souhaite que
vous puissiez nous faire partager le
bilan qui a été le vôtre à la au
gouvernement quelles sont vos motifs de
satisfaction quelles peuvent être quels
sont vos regrets et des sujets sur
lesquels vous auriez aimé aller encore
beaucoup plus loin et quels sont les
difficultés auxquelles vous avez dû
faire face les objectifs de distribution
de ma prime rénove que vous aviez
annoncé ont été atteints et même
dépassés environ 650
000 logements ont bénéficié de la prime
en 2021 cependant les rénovations
globales restent faibles et on peut bien
sûr le regretter Lana annonce avoir
financé 51
967 rénovations globale en 2021 avec
habiter mieux sérénité désormais m'a
prévenu ma prime rénov sérénité et ma
prime rénove copropriété
comment massifier le recours à ces
rénovations plus performantes pour
atteindre notre objectif de 500 000
logements réellement rénovés globalement
par an et pour leur jamais atteint par
ailleurs dans le déploiement de ma prime
rénove les difficultés de mise en œuvre
de Lana les risques de fraude ont-ils
été suffisamment anticipé
le recours à un cabinet de conseil en
l'occurrence Capgemini pour près de 28,5
millions d'euros au total était-il
justifié
assumez-vous d'avoir privilégié la
quantité des ménages et des à la qualité
des rénovations
comment expliquer vous que les fraudes
qu'il s'agisse des arnaques pures et
simples ou des malfaçons soient si
nombreuses et si peu sanctionner quelle
mesure avez-vous prises en la matière
la loi climat est résilience de 2021 a
fixé un calendrier d'interdiction de
location des passoires thermiques est-il
selon vous adapté afin de ne pas
gravement perturber le marché du
logement compte tenu des insuffisances
voire du manque de fiabilité du DPE et
des rénovations globales enfin avant de
vous laisser la parole pour répondre à
ses premières questions et pour un
propos introductif d'une quinzaine de
minutes il me revient de vous indiquer
que cette audition est diffusée en
direct et en différé sur le site
internet du Seda et qu'un compte rendu
sera publié je dois également vous
rappeler qu'un faux témoignage devant
notre commission d'enquête serait
passible des peines prévues aux articles
434-13
434-14 et 434-15 du code pénal qui
peuvent aller de trois ans à 7
emprisonnement et de 45.000 euros à
100000 euros d'amende je vous invite
donc monsieur le ministre a prêté
serment de dire toute la vérité rien que
la vérité a levé la main droite et à
dire je le jure je le jure merci
monsieur le ministre je vais donc vous
laisser la parole pour environ une
quinzaine de minutes ensuite bien sûr
monsieur le rapporteur vous posera un
certain nombre de questions et ensuite
nous ouvrirons le débat avec nos
collègues qui sont présents dans cette
salle c'est à vous monsieur le ministre
merci beaucoup
merci beaucoup madame la présidente
monsieur le rapporteur mesdames et
Messieurs les sénatrices et sénateurs
d'abord je voulais vous remercier de
vous être saisi de ce sujet au combien
important important évidemment d'un
point de vue climatique vous avez tous
en tête la question du rôle du logement
dans sa complétude vis-à-vis du
réchauffement climatique également d'un
point de vue social je voudrais vraiment
insister dessus
le réchauffement climatique et
probablement l'un des plus grands
vecteurs d'inégalités sociales
d'aujourd'hui encore plus de demain et
enfin d'un point de vue humain le
logement étant le lieu où nous passons
le plus de temps dans nos vies
évidemment qu'un logement mal isolé où
il fait froid l'hiver est un logement où
les enfants qui vivent ne peuvent pas
avoir les mêmes chances de réussite que
d'autres enfants en tout les chances
auxquelles ils auraient le droit ils ont
le droit et auquel ils aspirent fort
légitimement c'est donc un sujet
absolument essentiel et je crois que le
titre même de la commission qui tourne
autour de l'efficacité est évidemment ce
que nous cherchons tous de manière
transpartisante à améliorer et je
retrouve bien là l'état d'esprit du
Sénat de se poser la question de ces
efficacités dans ces politiques
publiques alors vous m'interrogez sur la
fois le bilan la satisfaction des
regrets et je voudrais au regard de cela
et en tentant de répondre de la manière
la plus complète possible à vos
différentes questions partagez un
certain nombre de retours d'expérience
permet des mois de commencer d'abord en
citant l'un de vos illustres
prédécesseurs sénateurs qui fut aussi
ministre du logement à savoir Edgar
Pisani et guerpeizani lorsqu'il
décrivait l'action et l'efficacité de
l'action politique disait que la
politique c'est avant tout deux choses
la vision et le quotidien et que la
bonne politique c'est celle qui repose
sur une vision et sur les effets du
quotidien la mauvaise politique étant
celle qui ne se focalise que sur les
outils je pense que cette phrase ou en
tout cas
cette paraphrase parce que ces termes ne
furent pas exactement cela de votre
prédécesseur Edgar Pisani résume assez
bien ce qu'il nous faut faire quant à la
politique du logement vous conviendrez
avec moi que très souvent lorsqu'on
parle de politique du logement on parle
beaucoup des outils des outils parfois
fort complexes des outils que nous
aimons à modifier en chaque loi de
finance que nous aimons à créer mais
revenir à la vision et revenir au
quotidien et probablement quelque chose
d'essentiel
la vision c'est celle que j'évoquais
tout à l'heure c'est-à-dire l'impérieuse
nécessité d'accélérer encore et encore
la rénovation thermique des bâtiments
d'un point de vue d'enjeux climatique
dont je social et danger humain et le
quotidien c'est de pouvoir avoir la
question du pilotage du nombre de
rénovations faites année après année et
je reviendrai sur ce sujet qui me paraît
au combien important et auquel j'ai été
confronté lorsque je fus ministre
délégué au logement et à David et juste
avant secrétaire d'État la cohésion des
territoires auprès de chaque message
au regard de cette
première considération
la deuxième considération que je
voudrais avec évoquer avec vous ce sont
des conclusions nécessaires pour mettre
en oeuvre cette vision et ce quotidien
et je voudrais partager avec vous cinq
premières conclusions
la première c'est que si on veut avoir
une vision faut absolument avoir un
temps long la grande difficulté en
politique c'est d'appréhender le temps
non la grande fragilité et le grand
simplisme en politique c'est de tomber
dans des politiques de l'émotion du
temps très court et d'abandonner le
temps non or il nous faut absolument
retrouver du temps non dans ces
politiques de logement c'est
probablement ce qu'il y a de plus
difficile et on est tous confrontés à
cela quand on est dans l'exécutif ou
quand on est parlementaire quand on est
élu de la Nation au niveau national au
niveau local remettre le temps long je
sais que parmi les questions que vous
vous posez il y a la question de la
planification avec une loi pluriduelle
de programmation je ne sais pas si le
bon outil la loi pluriannuelle ce que je
sais en tout cas c'est que la
planification et au combien importante
et dans tous ces détails je me souviens
par exemple avoir essayé de faire perdu
perdurer pardon des mécanismes je pense
à la fameuse garantie visale ou beaucoup
me disaient à partir du moment où on
change tout sur la garantie visale
changeons aussi le nom pour faire en
sorte que cette garantie soit attachée à
au mandat que j'exerçais ou au président
de la République et non pas à ceux qui
l'avaient créé juste avant j'ai toujours
considéré que c'était là une faute et
que le temps non c'était justement de
s'inscrire dans la durée à tous les
échelons y compris dans les
dénominations de ces outils qui ne
cessent d'être modifié année après année
la deuxième conclusion c'est qu'il faut
absolument absolument remettre l'humain
au centre de toutes nos politiques de
logement on parle pas assez d'humain et
quand on parle par exemple de rénovation
énergétique des bâtiments pour avoir en
préparation de cette audition écoutée
non pas la complétude des auditions que
vous avez faites mais plusieurs d'entre
elles et de manière très précise je
pense qu'il y a un terme qui n'a pas
encore été suffisamment mentionné qui
pour moi était essentiel c'est le côté
humain avec le reste à charge cette
notion du reste à charge est absolument
essentielle la question du reste à
charge zéro est absolument essentiel
faut-il avoir un reste à charge zéro et
si oui pour qui dans la mesure où le
reste à charge est souvent une barrière
pour beaucoup de nos concitoyens dans la
mise en place de ces travaux de
rénovation deuxième conclusion très
importante à mes yeux la troisième
conclusion c'est la gouvernance si nous
voulons absolument avoir une vision il
faut avoir une gouvernance qui soit
adaptée à ce titre je fais partie de
ceux qui considèrent qu'il est
totalement pertinent d'avoir un
ministère du Logement rattaché au
ministère de la transition
écologique je vous donne juste un
exemple
je l'ai vécu le ministère du logement
était en charge de la NA le ministère de
la transition écologique était en charge
des C2E comme a pu vous l'expliciter
Emmanuel Varon avec qui j'ai toujours
très très bien travaillé il est évident
que lorsque vous avez deux ministères
qui gèrent deux entités ou deux outils
qui sont parfois qui devraient être
absolument complémentaires mais qui sont
parfois pilotés par des structures qui
diffèrent à ce moment-là vous perdez
évidemment une partie d'efficacité dans
ses politiques publiques Emmanuel Vacon
vous a raconté également la façon dont
les questions avaient été posées je
n'étais plus alors au gouvernement dans
le pilotage de France Renov entre Lana
et l'ADEME la gouvernance de Lana et de
l'ADEME n'est pas la même si vous avez
un ministère du logement qui est
dissocié du ministère de la transition
écologique il me semble absolument
pertinent d'avoir ce ministère du
Logement rattaché au ministère de la
transition écologique
la quatrième conclusion si je sors de la
vision pour aller au quotidien c'est la
question du monitoring il n'y a pas de
politique publique sans monitoring il
n'y a pas de politique publique efficace
si nous ne sommes pas capables de dire à
chaque instant à chaque fin d'année quel
est le nombre de logements qui ont pu
être rénovés la qualité de ces
rénovations la dynamique de ces
rénovations et comparer ce nombre avec
des objectifs que nous nous étions
assignés lorsque j'ai été ministre
délégué au logement et à la ville je me
souviens très bien avoir demandé à mes
équipes de pouvoir publier au même
rythme que nous publions les
constructions neuves les rénovations des
bâtiments pourquoi vous en souvenez
madame la Présidente j'avais mis comme
priorité en tout cas l'une des
principales priorités de mon action à ce
moment-là la rénovation des bâtiments je
disais même je le souhaite de ministre
du Logement de la rénovation etc etc etc
mais il m'était impossible de publier
mes résultats il mettait donc aussi
impossible de savoir si les résultats
que j'avais étaient à la hauteur de ceux
sur lesquels je m'étais engagé votre
rôle en tant que Parlement qui juge est
au sens évalu l'action de gouvernement
en est que plus difficile et la
conséquence de tout cela a été des
travaux que nous avions mené pour
conduire jusqu'à la création de
l'Observatoire de la rénovation je crois
que vous avez auditionné d'ailleurs le
représentant de l'Observatoire et
aujourd'hui on sait bien qu'il y a
encore beaucoup de travail notamment
avec le décalage dans le temps de ces
chiffres mais il me paraît absolument
essentiel tout comme le ministère public
de manière régulière les chiffres de la
construction neuf que le ministère soit
en capacité de publier les chiffres de
la rénovation je pense d'ailleurs qu'il
faudrait le faire non pas que au niveau
national mais au niveau de départemental
avec une granulométrie géographique de
ces chiffres
la cinquième et dernière conclusion
c'est la question de l'accompagnement il
n'y a pas de politique publique sociale
efficace il n'y a pas d'accompagnement
c'est folie de croire que sous prétexte
que nous aurions inventé un très bon
outil que nous aurions voté ce très bon
outil dans une loi de finance qu'à ce
moment-là il se déploiera partout sur le
territoire ce n'est pas vrai il faut un
accompagnement et cet accompagnement il
est très compliqué parce que j'ai vécu
je me souviens très bien des moments où
des familles m'expliquées qu'ils avaient
dû taper à la porte de trois quatre cinq
guichets différents pour avoir la
possibilité de cumuler des différentes
aides qui du département de l'interco de
la région évidemment de l'état des
différentes entités éthiques pouvaient
leur donner afin d'avoir le reste à
charge le plus bas possible vous les
connaissez il y a même des associations
qui accompagnent les ménages les plus
précaires pour faire à leur place
l'ensemble de ces dossiers tellement ces
dossiers sont compliqués et le nombre
de personnes qui
qui contacter et est important c'était
en tout cas le cas lorsque j'ai été
nommé ministre du logement depuis lors
nous avons œuvré Emmanuel Varon a
énormément travaillé là-dessus je ne
reviens pas dessus elle vous l'a
explicité j'aurais juste une remarque à
titre personnel moi je n'ai jamais cru
au guichet unique je ne crois pas la
notion de guichet unique je pense qu'en
fait un guichet unique n'est à la fin
qu'un guichet additionnel que vous
rajoutez à tous les guichets existants
parce que je ne crois pas qu'un jour le
département la région où la nav va se
dire de toute manière moi j'arrête mon
guichet parce que c'est un autre qui va
le faire en revanche ce en quoi je crois
c'est que l'ensemble de ces guichets et
la capacité de proposer la même offre
pour l'ensemble de nos concitoyens et
que lorsqu'un guichet propose une offre
ce même guichet et lui la capacité
d'année interroger les autres guichets
qu'il connaît par cœur
puisqu'il travaille de manière régulière
avec eux pour que à la fin le citoyen
qui s'adresse à l'un de ces guichets
puissent bénéficier de l'offre de
l'ensemble des guichets dit autrement
pas de guichet unique des guichets
diverses mais avec une offre unique et
une offre unifiée il me paraît être là
le meilleur des systèmes possibles
une fois que je vous ai fait part de ces
principales conclusions quelques routes
sur le retour d'expérience quelques
points sur lesquels je souhaite revenir
que ce soit des moments de succès ou des
moments de regret en tout état tout état
de cause des questions que vous m'avez
posé ou que j'ai pu voir être au centre
de vos interrogations
le premier point et la question de la
transformation du crédit d'impôt en a
prime rénov je ne reviens pas sur la
genèse mes prédécesseurs vont dans les
auditions voulons expliciter en revanche
j'insiste sur le fait que pour moi c'est
la meilleure des décisions possible si
c'était à refaire je le referai fort
volontiers c'est un dossier que nous
avions mené de concert avec Emmanuel
wargon à la demande du Premier ministre
Édouard Philippe qui a donné lieu à
l'ouverture de l'imprimerie de neuf
début 2020 juste avant la pandémie de
covid si c'était à refaire je le referai
pour au moins une seule raison mais qui
elle seule me paraît totalement le
justifié qui est la question
d'accès d'accessibilité de ces aides
pour les ménages les plus précaires dans
la mesure où un crédit d'impôt diffère
d'une année voire un peu plus le
versement de l'aide dont
le ménage ont le droit cette question de
trésorerie est une question absolument
essentielle un crédit d'impôt n'est pas
un outil d'aide sociale ou en tout cas
le plus social possible ma prime rénove
a un effet
social beaucoup plus important en ce
sens où elle permet de faire face à la
question de la trésorerie et évidemment
beaucoup de ménages les plus fragiles
n'ont pas cette capacité de faire
l'avance le deuxième élément et vous
l'avez dit madame la Présidente je vous
en remercie les ambitions que nous
avions fixées ont été au rendez-vous se
pose toutefois une question et c'est
celle de la rénovation globale versus
des gestes
le deuxième point sur lequel je voudrais
insister c'est que pour moi il est très
important
d'aller vers l'idéal cette rénovation
globale sans jamais renier la réalité
des choses c'est-à-dire que il y a un
parcours de rénovation et que ce
parcours de rénovation nécessite de
pouvoir continuer à financer les gestes
j'en ai la conviction la plus certaine
quitte à ce que lorsque on finance un
geste
une opération de rénovation pour un
ménage que évidemment l'accompagnement
puisse aussi donner des informations sur
l'intérêt d'autres réalisations et
d'intérêt de la rénovation globale la
deuxième des conclusions pour moi c'est
que il ne faudrait surtout pas arrêter
de financer des gestes pour ne faire que
des financements de rénovation ce serait
là aussi quelque chose qui ne serait pas
social à mes yeux et efficace la
troisième des
troisième point sur lequel je voulais
insister c'est la question de
l'interdiction versus ainsi incitation
et se faisant répondre à ce que vous
m'avez posé comme question sur la sur le
volet de l'interdiction de la location
ou les autres dispositifs notamment au
moment des mutations
moi je fais partie de ceux qui
considèrent que l'incitation vaut
toujours mieux que l'interdiction ça ne
veut pas dire qu'il ne faut pas faire
d'interdiction
mais en toute état de cause
l'interdiction n'est jamais suffisante
sauf dans des cas très très précis je
pense évidemment à tout le combat que
nous avions pu mener ensemble d'ailleurs
madame la Présidente sur les marchands
de sommeil où là évidemment la main ne
doit jamais trembler et il faut
absolument avoir des procédures de
d'interdiction très forte mais
l'incitation me paraît être quelque
chose d'extrêmement important à ce titre
j'ai un regret c'est
de voir que il me semble que le
dispositif que nous avions créé qui
portait qui porte toujours mon nom le 2
Normandie dans l'ancien à mes yeux est
un dispositif très pertinent pourquoi
nous l'avions résumé ainsi à l'époque
enfin je l'avais résumé ainsi à l'époque
ayez la défiscalisation heureuse
défiscaliser grâce à la rénovation des
bâtiments et à la rénovation de nos
centres-villes plutôt que
l'urbanisation périurbaine
dans de la construction
de
extra centre-ville
ça ne veut pas dire que je porte un
jugement sur la nature de l'habitat mais
je parle là de la défiscalisation et de
son et de son utilisation il me semble
que nous devons continuer à promouvoir
de telles dispositif incitatif et faire
en sorte que cette défiscalisation
puisse permettre la rénovation et puisse
permettre la revitalisation des
centres-villes ne paraît être de très
très bonnes politiques
sur cette incitation versus interdiction
il y a aussi donc la question de
l'interdiction des logements de la
location versus d'autres dispositifs
le ministre François de Rugy vous a
évoqué notamment les débats que nous
avions à l'époque François d'orugy alors
d'abord il y a un engagement du
Président de la République pris en tant
que candidat en 2017 d'interdire à la
location les passoires thermiques
engagement qui a été depuis leur tenue
par les lois que vous avez évoquées
madame la Présidente mais c'est vrai que
il y a là un impact social évident la
question est donc de mettre le bon
curseur pour s'assurer que un mal qu'on
essaye de résoudre nous ne soyons pas en
train de créer un autre mal avec un
impact social très important et donc la
question de mécanisme
a été évoqué notamment le ministre
d'origine avait proposé de mettre en
place un dispositif connu que certains
certaines autres personnes proposent qui
est de dire que au moment où on vend un
bien le montant des travaux de la
rénovation nécessaire et en quelque
sorte séquestrée et déduit du montant de
la vente moi j'ai toujours été fermement
opposé à ce mécanisme là pour une raison
très simple mais c'est peut-être là
aussi toujours ma fibre très sociale
c'est qu'en fait c'est quelque chose qui
empêche
ou plutôt favori c'est quelque chose qui
favorise l'assignation à résidence je
vous prends juste un exemple
si vous avez un pavillon en zone
détendue qui nécessite des travaux de
rénovation et que vous trouvez un
travail en zone tendue et évidemment
alors la réalité il y a 4 ans
du marché du travail n'est pas la même
que celle d'aujourd'hui où on a un
marché du travail qui est fort
heureusement qui se porte beaucoup mieux
il y a quatre ans c'était pas la
situation le taux de chômage était plus
élevé que aujourd'hui
quand vous vous trouvez un travail dans
une zone
qui souvent est plus une zone tendue
qu'une zone détendue quand je parle de
manière générale du marché du travail
encore une fois il y a quatre ans un peu
plus à ce moment-là si vous vous dites
pour vous loger vous vendez votre maison
pour aller acheter un appartement ou une
maison dans cette zone tendue qu'est-ce
qui va se passer votre maison dans la
zone détendue va voir sa valeur
totalement diminuée du montant séquestre
des travaux en zone tendu le
différentiel sera bien moindre parce que
la zone est entendue le prix du marché
n'incorporera pas des factômes le
montant du du séquestre et donc
qu'est-ce que vous allez créer comme
phénomène à nouveau une assignation à
résidence et donc moi j'ai toujours été
au nom de ce principe d'assignation de
lutte contre l'assignation à résidence
opposée à ce mécanisme à ce mécanisme là
je dis pas que celui qui a été voté le
plus parfait en tout cas je pense qu'il
est mieux que celui consistant à mettre
en place un séquestre tel que certains
de mes collègues le propos à l'époque et
qui a fait l'objet de discussion tout à
fait constructive entre nous
est-ce que le calendrier proposé est
aujourd'hui le mieux je ne serai le dire
n'étant plus
les mains dans le dans le dossier mais
je suis sûr que vous aurez l'occasion de
poser la question au ministre actuel
incitation versus
interdiction je pense que à ce titre
c'était de très bonnes politiques
d'ouvrir ma prime rénove au bailleur et
je pense que c'est une politique qu'il
faut continuer ça a été un débat pendant
de longs mois et un débat assez
récurrent de savoir fallait-il ou pas
ouvrir ma prime rénove au pailleur je
pense que oui et je pense que c'est
c'était véritablement de traine très
bonne politique incitation versus
interdiction en tout était cause
information ça renvoie toutes les bases
sur la fiabilisation du DPE n'est pas
compliqué sujet technique compliqués
mais au combien important
enfin et pour ne pas être trop long je
voudrais vous faire part de deux trois
derniers points sur le retour
d'expérience d'abord sur la question des
outils de financement moi je pense qu'en
fait il faut qu'on réalise que
contrairement à ce que
alors ça n'a jamais été mon cas parce
que j'en suis convaincu depuis des
années mais contrairement à ce que
certains ont essayé parfois de dire dans
le débat public je pense qu'en fait la
rénovation énergétique des bâtiments
n'est pas quelque chose de rentable
pour la personne qui habite dans le
bâtiment sur un temps court c'est-à-dire
sur le temps de l'habitation de ce
bâtiment je rappelle qu'en moyenne quand
vous êtes propriétaire d'un logement
vous restez 8 ans et demi dans ce
logement huit ans et demi or très rare
sont les opérations de rénovation
énergétique qui ont une rentabilité sur
8 ans et demi et je pense que ce
postulat il faut le prendre en compte
parce que souvent et souvenez-vous on a
cherché des prêts à taux zéro des prêts
un peu bonifiés etc etc en disant bah là
on va avoir une rentabilité de
l'opération pour le ménage moi je pense
pas je pense qu'en fait il faut assumer
le fait que si on veut faire des
rénovations du fait de cette temporalité
dans le logement il faut accepter de
pouvoir surventionner une partie de ces
travaux la rénovation thermique sans
subvention est à mes yeux quelque chose
dans l'équation économique ne marche pas
ou en tout cas ne marche pas
suffisamment rapidement au cas
particulier j'ai un regret parce que je
n'ai pas réussi et je n'ai aussi parce
que nous n'avions pas véritablement
trouvé l'idée c'est la question de la
rénovation thermique des copropriétés
alors vous souvenez madame la présidente
des copropriétés j'en avais fait un axe
très fort de mon action nous avions vécu
le drame de la rue d'Aubagne à Marseille
nous avions lancé quelques semaines
avant ce drame de la rue d'Aubagne à
Marseille le plan copro dégradé sur
lequel vous étiez aussi impliqué je vous
en remercie et c'est copropriété
dégradée en fait la question de la
rénovation est un vrai sujet moi ma
conviction mais je sais que le président
de la commission Environnement
du Parlement européen parce qu'elle
campe avait émis aussi cette idée dans
le débat moi je pense que la meilleure
des solutions et que nous n'avons pas
encore trouvé c'est de faire en sorte
que ça ne soit pas le propriétaire qui
s'endette mais de faire en sorte que
soit la copropriété qui s'endette parce
que le propriétaire à partir du moment
où il reste 8 ans et demi dans son en
moyenne dans son logement
il n'a pas le temps de voir la
rentabilité des travaux en tout cas
de manière certaine si demain on arrive
à faire en sorte que ce soit la
copropriété qui s'endette et qu'au
moment où il y a une mutation dans le
logement et bien il y a un portage de la
dette de nouveaux propriétaires vers de
l'ancien propriétaire vers le nouveau
propriétaire donc quelque chose qui peut
se rapprocher sur ces opérations de tir
financement mais qui soit vraiment avec
une entité juridique de la copropriété
qui est la capacité de s'endetter il me
semble que ce serait quelque chose de
très pertinent il y a un réseau avec
lequel on nous avions tenté de
travailler dessus que vous connaissez
bien Madame la Présidente c'est le
réseau pro CIVIS avec son président
Yannick board où nous avions tenté de
porter de telle dispositif il me semble
que c'est vraiment une solution
une solution à creuser enfin il y a
facilité des décisions dans les
copropriétés nous avons payé pour voir
dans le cadre de la loi élan dont vous
étiez la rapporteur et sur lequel nous
avions essayé de de frais
les deux derniers points et pardon
d'avoir été trop longs trois derniers
points très rapides un les bailleurs
sociaux évidemment sont une partie
intégrante je ne reviens pas sur ce que
nous avions pu faire sur la rue le
doublement des financements de la rue
d'accélération incroyablement importante
mais deux points sur lequel je voulais
attirer votre attention parce que peu
commun le premier des éléments
ayant en tête que le ministère du
logement avant que en tout cas quand je
suis arrivé n'avait pas la tutelle ni la
mise à disposition de la direction de
l'immobilier de l'État qui comme vous le
savez les dieux est un organe qui dépend
de Bercy et notamment du ministère du
Budget
je m'étais battu à l'époque et j'avais
eu la mise à disposition si je m'en
souviens pas non pas la tutelle mais la
mise à disposition de la DIY pourquoi je
dis ça parce que je sais que pendant vos
auditions beaucoup ont insisté sur
des questions de porter là-dessus sur la
rénovation des bâtiments publics des
bâtiments l'état etc etc il me semble
absolument essentiel que le ministère du
Logement puisse avoir
à minima la mise à disposition voir dans
un monde idéal la Coutelle de la die la
die ne doit pas être un organe qui ne
soit vu que avec un prisme budgétaire
mais bien avec une politique une
politique d'habitat et pas qu'une
politique de logement d'ailleurs on
parle de logement mais évidemment tout
cela relève de l'habitat et enfin pour
terminer une vaste question mais qui je
suis sur vous passionnera c'est la
question de la décentralisation
une vraie question moi je suis pour une
décentralisation des politiques de
logement pour un principe très simple
qui je le sais cher Président de la
République c'est que lorsque vous votez
pour le chef de l'État en fait vous ne
votez pas pour une politique de logement
quand vous volez pour votre mère ou
votre président
d'Interco par des facto vous votez pour
les politiques d'habitat et donc en fait
vous avez une décoration entre celui qui
est en charge de la politique et le
processus démocratique afférent donc par
définition moi je suis pour une
décentralisation des politiques de
logements c'est pour ça que j'ai
d'ailleurs vous souvenez madame la
Présidente toujours été opposé au
retrait du permis de construire dans la
main des mers
la question de la décentralisation des
politiques de logement est très
compliquée
très compliqué
parce que beaucoup d'outils fiscaux et
on sait à quel point décentraliser des
politiques fiscales c'est incroyablement
compliqué
parce que dans la rénovation des
bâtiments typiquement c'est quand même
très utile d'avoir une agence qui est au
niveau national fixe les outils le cas
le budget et cette force de frappe
en revanche probablement de
l'accompagnement peut être beaucoup plus
déconcentré
probablement
les la façon dont les aides sont
distribuées peut-être beaucoup plus
déconcentrés probablement donner la
capacité au département plus que les
régions d'ailleurs et qui pourtant
aujourd'hui ont la compétence sur cette
rénovation moi je pense que c'est
beaucoup ça relève beaucoup plus du
département au titre des politiques
sociales vous l'aurez compris je on m'a
dit j'ai pas vérifié mais on m'a dit que
en Grande-Bretagne des médecins avaient
le droit de prescrire la rénovation des
bâtiments
je ne sais pas si c'est vrai mais je le
trouve en tout cas que si ça l'est c'est
formidable si ça ne l'est pas en tout
état de cause ça résume bien aussi un
élément de cette politique sociale qui
fait que les départements et un rôle à
jouer encore plus fort et à mes yeux
essentiels mais cette déconcentration
versus décentralisation en tout cas la
territorialisation de nos politiques de
rénovation et probablement un enjeu
absolument essentiel je le pose plus
comme une direction que comme une
solution n'ayant moi-même pas eu ni le
temps ni la possibilité
de travailler là-dessus de manière très
précise mais je pense que c'est le sens
de l'histoire une émissez si j'ai été
trop long
pas du tout monsieur le ministre c'était
bien sûr très intéressant alors vous
n'avez pas répondu à toute la question
concernant
l'anticipation des problématiques de
fraude d'arnaque voir des phénomènes
mais je pense que monsieur le rapporteur
peut-être il reviendra donc voilà on
vous laissera la parole sur ce sujet là
également je laisse la parole à Monsieur
le Rapporteur
merci Madame madame la Présidente merci
monsieur le ministre pour
pour ce balayage et puis cette exposé
très très complet effectivement qui qui
a bien balayé l'ensemble des
problématiques qu'on a pu rencontrer et
puis à travers les différentes les
différentes auditions
peut-être revenir bon il y avait déjà
par rapport à votre votre introduction
c'est vrai sur les modèles de guerre
pzanie je pense que sur la question à la
fois du d'une vision politique et du
temps long on voit bien que encore plus
peut-être sur ce type de politique là on
a ce besoin là sauf que c'est vrai que
c'est pour le coup ce qu'on entend
souvent mais la difficulté du coup de de
mettre en place ce type justement de
politique sur un temps long lié à notre
fonctionnement tout simplement tout
simplement politique donc ça
m'intéressait de voir justement comment
à travers notre fonctionnement on
pouvait peut-être avoir plus de de de
réflexion sur ce sur ce temps long donc
on a parlé d'une d'une loi de
programmation ça peut être effectivement
un outil
peut-être si vous pouviez aussi revenir
sur donc vous avez parlé de tout
l'intérêt en tout cas de la prime rénov
par rapport au crédit d'impôt en tout
cas que c'était quelque chose que à la
fois que vous aviez appuyé sur lequel
vous ne reviendrez pas en tout cas qui
était une bonne plutôt une bonne chose
mais si vous pouviez aller peut-être
plus loin justement puisque pour le coup
dans les différents ministres alors
forcément ça dépendait de ce qu'ils ont
mis en place ou pas mais en tout cas on
a eu des retours qui pouvaient être
assez différents donc ça m'intéressait
peut-être d'avoir quelque chose d'un peu
plus un peu plus précis et puis ça fera
le lien aussi peut-être avec la fraude
parce que c'est vrai que comme ce que
vous avez dit on a ces outils qui
peuvent être mis en place et puis à
derrière ce qu'ils engendrent il y a
comme les l'impact qui peuvent avoir les
effets de ces outils et forcément la
question de de la fraude des dérives à
la fois de l'effet de levier mais aussi
des effets inverses qu'on pourrait qu'on
pourrait avoir ça ça me paraissait aussi
important si vous pliez préciser ça
sur la question du du pilotage donc
c'est vrai comme beaucoup de vos
collègues vous avez plaidé pour avoir le
lien entre ministère de la transition
écologique et ministère du Logement et
d'avoir un ministère du Logement à part
entière ça me paraît aussi quelque chose
d'important je fais le lien avec ce que
vous avez dit à la fin sur l'exemple de
la de la Grande-Bretagne enfin même si
on verra si c'est une réalité ou pas
mais en tout cas le lien avec aussi le
Mister aux affaires sociales il faut que
la santé enfin voilà mais en tout cas
sur cette sur cet aspect là parce que
c'est vrai qu'on voit bien que quand on
travaille sur la question du logement de
la rénovation du logement il y a la
question de la santé derrière très très
directement quand on vit dans une dans
une passoire thermique et puis comme
vous avez dit il y a des gens enfin je
veux dire il y a vraiment de l'humain
derrière tout ça et donc c'est vrai que
ce lien aussi avec le mystère des
affaires sociales peut avoir son son
intérêt ou son importance je voulais
savoir déjà si c'est quelque chose qui
avait déjà été mis en oeuvre en tout cas
il y avait des liens avec ce ministère
ou en tout cas est-ce que ce que enfin
voilà votre avis là-dessus
rapidement sur l'accompagnement vous
avez parlé sur la votre avis était
intéressant sur la question du geshinic
peut-être plus sur ce qui est en train
de se mettre en place avec avec France
Renov et notamment vous avez aussi parlé
sur la décentralisation mais la question
du de la place des collectivités et du
local et comment justement vous vous
voyez réellement comment peuvent se
mettre en place parce que c'est vrai
qu'on voit et qu'on a sur certains
secteurs sur certains astres
communalités des outils plutôt
intéressants qui existent qui
fonctionnent et souvent lié à des
politiques plus nationales souvent on
peut revenir en arrière ou en tout cas
on peut venir recomplexifier quelque
chose qui pouvait fonctionner vous la
voir aussi votre votre sentiment
là-dessus
et puis mais vous l'avez répondu enfin
je l'avais noté mais c'était sur ça
m'intéressait sur la question justement
à la fois le choix qui a été fait sur
les locations de décider plutôt de de
contraindre en fait les locations
interdiction des locations des passoires
thermiques plutôt justement de faire la
rénovation à la vente et c'est vrai que
c'est François d'orugy effectivement qui
avait expliqué un peu ça et puis cette
arbitrage là mais pour le coup vous avez
vous avez vous avez répondu mais
peut-être faire le lien avec le reste à
charge 0 vous en avez parlé aussi c'est
vrai que c'est forcément une question
qu'on se pose se dire que comme si on
veut que ça avance forcément notamment
pour les plus faibles revenus on voit
bien qu'il y a cette nécessité d'avoir
cette reste à charge zéro mais pour le
coup quel mécanisme on peut mettre en
place donc savoir si vous aviez en tout
cas réfléchi à cette à cette question
et puis une dernière petite
deux petites derrière question une par
rapport à ce qui avait été dit par par
votre collègue sur la question du du
budget du et du du financement on voit
bien que c'est forcément il faut de
l'argent mais on voit bien que ce n'est
pas qu'une qu'une question d'argent et
en tout cas la question de l'utilisation
de cette cet argent mais on nous a
plusieurs de vos collègues nous ont
quand même dit que notamment si on voit
les on voulait aller vers une rénovation
globale performante et plutôt rapide qui
qui manquerait enfin qu'il faudrait au
moins un milliard supplémentaire donc
voilà mais savoir si vous aviez une
aussi un avis un avis là-dessus et puis
pour terminer c'est ensuite un mes
collègues vous avez été ministre de
l'Agriculture je trouvais intéressant
puisqu'on réfléchit aussi à travers
cette mission sur la rénovation et le
lien au matériaux biosourcés
on voit que voilà les rénovation qui est
faite actuellement et à 90% avec des
produits issus de la
pétrochimie que il y a des filières à
mettre en place que bon encore un petit
peu de mal et forcément en lien avec
l'agriculture parce que ça peut être que
ça soit la paille que ce soit le change
que ce soit l'un etc avec différents
types de matériaux et qui sont en plus
très complémentaires avec d'autres types
d'agriculture voilà voir votre avis
aussi sur cette question et le
développement qu'on pourrait avoir sur
ces matériaux biosourcés et qui
permettront aussi de répondre à une
pénurie de matériaux dans le secteur
voilà merci
je vous laisse la parole monsieur le
ministre simplement plutôt que de parler
de reste à charge zéro pense pas que il
faudrait mieux parler de reste à charge
minimale
alors
merci monsieur le rapporteur sur la
question du temps long c'est c'est
d'abord une volonté politique
c'est une volonté politique c'est-à-dire
que c'est une feuille de route c'est un
parfois un engagement de campagne
c'est en toute état de cause un
engagement du de l'exécutif et une
capacité de l'exécutif à pouvoir
donner un sens planifié et
dire année après année si ce sens et
cette planification sont bien respectées
si je crois le sens de la planification
écologique voulue par le président de la
République Emmanuel Macron c'est je
crois le sens donné
à la à la première ministre dans son
décret d'attribution en ce sens où elle
est aussi responsable des politiques
écologiques c'est le sens de la de
structuration y compris de ce
secrétariat général à l'écologie je
peut-être que je me trompe sur son sur
le la dénomination mais et vous voyez la
structure bref c'est d'abord une volonté
c'est ensuite probablement une hygiène
collective
je pense que nous sommes beaucoup à
souhaiter cette planification et cette
vision de long terme et je crois pouvoir
dire avec beaucoup d'humilité parce que
j'ai très certainement moi aussi pêché
mais que nous avons été certains au fur
et à mesure des années à être les
premiers à modifier des dispositifs dans
le cadre de loi de finances
et je dis ça sans de manière très
constructive mais c'est une réalité qui
nous faut admettre
c'est probablement
la question de de la plurielleualité
dans les dispositifs et les outils
l'exemple le plus criant
[Musique]
sur votre deuxième point ma primerie
note rénov pardon versus le cite
mais c'est probablement mon
aspiration sociale enfin on encre social
moi je n'ai aucun doute sur le fait que
à partir du moment où vous avez un
dispositif plus redistributif plus
social plus accessible
ça suffit en tant que tel à choisir ce
dispositif versus le crédit d'impôt vous
noterez que ça vient en contradiction
avec ce que j'ai dit avant sur le temps
long ce qui prouve bien à quel point le
temps long et quand même compliqué
la question et ça fait ça fait un bien
avec votre septième point la question du
montant avait été un sujet très débattu
parce qu'au moment de la transformation
du CPE en ma primerie neuve il y avait
eu en plus un rabot sur les montants des
politiques d'efficacité énergétiques du
fait d'un recentrage avec l'exclusion
d'un certain nombre de gestes etc
probablement que cela avait aussi
conduit à
animer un débat peut-être plus sur
d'ailleurs le montant que sur la
pertinence du dispositif à la fin des
fins du fait des ajouts budgétaires et
des et des différents plans de renonce
je crois pouvoir dire mais mais je parle
sous votre contrôle que les budgets ont
été au final
réhaussé à des niveaux comparables à ce
qu'ils étaient auparavant et donc on en
vient un système où vous avez matrimerie
neuf plutôt que crédit d'impôt avec des
montants qui sont somme toute
équivalents à ce qu'ils étaient je parle
encore une fois sous votre contrôle
n'ayant plus tous les chiffres en tête
et je pense que c'est très bien ainsi
sur la question de la fraude
je pense pouvoir dire et je fais quoi
est-ce que vous disiez la ministre
Ségolène Royale qui vantait la
simplicité du crédit d'impôt en disant
pour un crédit d'impôt suffit de cocher
trois cas sur une sur une déclaration de
revenus ou enfin d'impôts je suis pas
sûr que ce soit
gage de plus de sécurité que ma prime
rénov ou vous allez un véritable dossier
à faire
ce qui est sûr c'est que les fraudes
ensuite la fraude pardon ensuite à cela
vu que moi j'ai mis en place ma prime
rénov avec Emmanuel baron mais ensuite
il y a eu la covid et ensuite j'ai
changé le ministère je n'ai eu
à les gérer dans les fraudes de ma prime
rénov donc je ou que quelques-unes mais
pas suffisamment
représentatif il y a un point sur lequel
on avait beaucoup oeuvré qui était
précédent des précédents d'ailleurs je
crois ma prime rénove au concombre
notamment c'est le démarchage
téléphonique
véritable fléau et je sais que le
législateur que vous représentez s'en
est saisi c'est la formation notamment
de tout le réseau d'artisans etc etc qui
est un enjeu haut combien important la
main ne doit jamais trembler quand il
s'agit de fraude à l'évidence après il
peut y avoir aussi quelques effets moi
j'ai toujours fait partie de ceux qui
considéraient que je préférais avoir
quelques effets domaines mais un
véritable impact social que très peu
d'impact parce qu'il est frayé par les
quelques effets domaines tout est
question de d'équilibre et de curseur
sur la question du ministère du lien
avec le ministère des affaires sociales
oui archiwi il y a juste une limite
quand on dit qu'on met tout le ministère
du logement dans le ministère de la
transition écologique c'est que je pense
qu'il ne faut jamais oublier que la
politique du logement n'est rien sans
politique de l'habitat et que
probablement le plus important c'est
quand même la politique de l'habitat et
il y a véritablement une question du
lien entre le ministère du Logement le
ministère de la Ville
ministère de la Ville qui a un véritable
aspect de politique sociale également et
je pense qu'il ne faut jamais oublier
que la véritable
politique c'est celle de l'habitat
ça renvoie d'ailleurs à votre point dans
suite sur le lien que je peux faire avec
la fonction qui a été la mienne au sein
du ministère de l'Agriculture de
l'Alimentation typiquement les zéro
artificialisation nette sujet ou combien
compliqués mais intrinsèquement lié à la
rénovation parce que le fait de ne plus
pouvoir construire autant que certains
le désiraient et bien renforce la
rénovation et d'ailleurs renforce le
différentiel enfin moins de différenciel
de coût entre la construction neuve et
la rénovation donc les deux sont
intrinsèquement liés je faisais une
conférence il y a peu sur la zéro
artificialisation nette et je disais
qu'en fait le meilleur de la terre était
probablement la ville à partir du moment
où on arrivait à retrouver une
attractivité de la ville et des
centres-villes il n'y a par définition
on faisait moins d'artifices
d'artificialisation des sols c'est un
sujet incroyablement complexe
village ville et villages zone
vous avez tout à fait raison monsieur le
sénateur et c'est vrai que c'est pour
moi quelque chose d'incroyablement
important sachant que la zéro
artificialisation nette je le dis et le
redis parce que c'est ça a toujours été
quelque chose que j'ai eu chevillé au
corps ça doit être quelque chose de
dynamique qui serions-nous pour
aujourd'hui en 2023 figer l'état de
notre pays pendant les décennies à venir
empêchant n'importe quel village de se
développer ou n'importe quel bourde de
pouvoir se développer donc ça doit être
dynamique c'est quelque chose
d'incroyablement important à mes yeux
sur l'accompagnement la place des
collectivités locales moi je pense que
l'accompagnement c'est le elle est verte
c'est la proximité ça veut pas dire que
les plateformes numériques ne sont pas
importantes elles sont même essentielles
ça veut pas dire que la puissance de la
nage voudrait vraiment mais vraiment
saluer le travail fait permanent et les
équipes de Lana avec qui j'ai travaillé
main dans la main avec Emmanuel vargon
sur ce dossier qui était compliqué mais
entre dans un monde idéal il faudrait
qu'une collectivité locale qui est au
plus près des concitoyens et la capacité
de distribuer l'aide de l'ANAH d'y
ajouter ce qu'elle souhaite ajouter de
le de
comment dit-on le l'adapter faire du
coup humain comme il souhaite le faire
en sortant de toute querelle de chapelle
on explicitant je pense que c'est très
important qui fait quoi ce que dans le
moment où il y a des crises
démocratiques comme celle que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui je pense que
c'est très important y compris qu'une
collectivité locale aucune agence de
l'État
indique bien que c'est la solidarité
nationale qui vient financer tout cela
et que cette salutarité n'est pas liée
que à l'élue locale n'est pas liée que à
l'agent qui travaille à Lana elle est
liée à la contribution de toutes celles
et ceux qui payent des impôts ou qui
payent de la TVA tous les citoyens dans
les budgets que ce sont des choix de de
budget je pense que c'est très important
de montrer de montrer cela mais en tout
état de cause pour moi tel elle doit
être le lien avec les collectivités
locales sur le reste à charge zéro ou le
reste à charge minimal vous avez raison
Madame la Présidente c'est probablement
du reste à charge il n'y a minimale ou
du reste à charge
acceptable
en tout état de cause je pense que la
bonne entrée c'est toujours de remettre
l'humain et l'humain il se dit pas
est-ce que la somme qu'on propose c'est
bien si c'est 6000 9000 12000 c'est à la
fin moi combien je dois payer et combien
ça représente par rapport à dans
l'accompagnement vraiment j'insiste
parce que je l'ai vécu j'espère que
c'est moins le cas aujourd'hui mais en
tout cas au tout début on voyait des cas
où c'était des associations qui venaient
accompagner et je les salue grandement
qui venait accompagner des ménages
précaires pour faire tous les dossiers
parce que parfois il y avait quatre cinq
six dossiers à faire pour avoir la
confiture des aides et pouvoir avoir un
reste à charge soit zéro soit acceptable
sur le budget financement est-ce que
c'est un milliard le fameux milliard je
ne saurais dire n'ayant pas les des
chiffres en tête monsieur le rapporteur
et sur les matériaux biosourcés oui
archi oui
madame la Présidente s'en souvient parce
que nous l'avions fait y compris dans la
loi élan ou dans le la R20 j'avais
énormément poussé mais c'est mon refrain
ne me refera pas c'est mon côté
ingénieur agronome et des eaux et forêt
mais j'avais énormément poussé pour la
construction bois dans toute la R20 et
les matériaux biosourcés évidemment
concours à la rénovation que ce soit
commencée par le chanvre magnifique
plante que vous évoquiez tout à l'heure
donc oui archiwi sur ces matériaux
biosourcés
merci Monsieur le Ministre alors il y a
déjà Martha de Sidrac qui souhaite vous
poser une question merci madame la
présidente monsieur le ministre je vous
remercie pour les quelques éclairages
que vous nous avez déjà donné je voulais
revenir sur mon sang enfin sur Votre
prisme et votre approche très social on
sent que vous êtes très attaché à cet
aspect là de la problématique qui nous
réunit aujourd'hui toutefois vous avez
aussi partagé avec nous votre souhait de
permettre au logement d'être affilié
voir sous tutelle de la transit avec
ministère de la transition écologique ça
tombe très bien puisque nous notre
commission d'enquête entre autres porte
sur l'efficacité de justement de la
rénovation énergétique du logement donc
première question
dans la mesure où vous avez partagé ce
souhait est-ce que c'est quelque chose
que vous aviez déjà manifesté lorsque
vous étiez en ministre et pourquoi
l'arbitrage ne s'est pas fait comme vous
avait souhaité qu'il se fasse donc
est-ce que vous pouvez nous donner
quelques éléments de réponse là-dessus
je voulais également
revenir sur ce que vous aviez dit en
disant que
et que vous étiez plutôt pour une pour
une enfin que vous pensiez à la
trésorerie des ménages et que donc vous
étiez plutôt pour une approche sociale
que donc la prime rénove en l'occurrence
plutôt que sur le crédit d'impôt ma
question en réalité porte sur les
classes moyennes et parce que dès lors
qu'on parle d'aide vous avez d'ailleurs
dans vos propos aussi rajouter sur le
fait que vous étiez vous ne pensiez pas
qu'ils pouvaient y avoir une politique
de rénovation énergétique sans
subventions donc ces aides là on sait
qu'aujourd'hui en France on a un certain
nombre de dispositifs vis-à-vis des
classes les plus modestes en revanche de
quelle manière être certain que je
dirais l'ensemble des Français
pourraient bénéficier d'un certain
nombre d'aides de dispositifs sans que
ça des usines à gaz et qui permettrait à
tout un chacun d'arriver à une
rénovation énergétique puisque c'est
l'objet en réalité aussi de ces
interrogations que nous avons au sein de
la commission d'enquête et donc
permettre à tout un chacun au-delà de la
catégorie dans laquelle il pourrait se
trouver d'accéder à des aides puisque
vous l'avez rappelé vous-même les
logements on change de logement on n'a
pas forcément envie d'investir dans un
logement qu'on sait qu'on va devoir
quitter et on n'est pas tous éligible à
des aides donc ça c'est aussi ma
deuxième question et j'aurais souhaité
avoir votre réflexion comment vous voyez
cet articulation autour de ça et je
terminais je terminerai par une de une
de vos réflexions que je trouve très
intéressante sur le guichet unique je
partage ce que vous disiez et je pense
qu'effectivement il est intéressant ça
va dans le sens de la décentralisation
aussi
de permettre d'avoir effectivement
différents guichets qui sans doute nous
permettrait de rendre
accessible un certain nombre de
dispositifs à l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens plutôt qu'un seul dispositif
qui serait plus ou moins décliné dans
nos territoires donc voilà donc j'avais
essentiellement les deux premières
questions pour lesquelles j'aurais
souhaité avoir votre réponse monsieur le
ministre je vous remercie
Joël Bigot qui parlera
merci madame la présidente madame la
sénatrice sur la question de
de l'approche sociale et la question du
périmètre ministériel deux éléments de
réponse
en fait je pense que vous l'aurez
compris moi je fais partie de ceux qui
considèrent que il n'y aura il n'y aura
pas de politique de transition
écologique cette politique de transition
écologique n'est pas une politique
très fortement axée sur son caractère
social il faut toujours le redire le
changement climatique et sera l'un des
principaux éléments de fracture
et d'inégalités sociales aujourd'hui et
demain le changement climatique ne fait
qu'accélérer les inégalités sociales
et donc
à partir du moment où le ministère du
Logement est mise sous une ministère de
la transition écologique c'est pour moi
à l'évidence ou sinon ça n'est pas un
ministère de la transition écologique
telle que je le conçois un ministère qui
est profondément ancré dans les
politiques sociales tout simplement
parce que si ça n'est pas le cas ça ne
marchera jamais ce sont les personnes
les plus aisées qui ont les bilan
carbone les plus élevés ce sont les
personnes les plus aisées qui ont la
capacité de payer des taxes carbone et
ce sont les personnes les moins aisées
qui souffrent le plus des conséquences
du changement
climatique ce qui est vrai en France est
encore plus heureux un international y
compris dans les relations
internationales donc oui archiwi il faut
que cette politique écologique soit une
politique sociale et c'est pour moi un
c'est consubstantiel
pourquoi cet arbitrage n'avait pas eu
lieu quand
j'étais en poste en fait la réalité
c'est quand j'ai été nommé la structure
gouvernementale était déjà ainsi et
j'étais avec comme ministre de tutelle
Jacques mesards qui lui-même était
ministre la cohésion des territoires
avec un très fort impact social
Jacques mesarques vous connaissez
bien si ce n'est Parker dans cette
maison
a toujours eu à l'oeuvre enfin à coeur
devrait en faveur de la lutte contre ses
factures fractures pardon territoriales
et le logement en faisait partie
maintenant
au moment où il y a eu un changement de
de d'architecture gouvernementale au
moment de la dénomination
d'un nouveau gouvernement
moi j'avais plaidé à titre personnel
pour que le ministère du logement soit
rattaché au ministère de la transition
écologique
je l'avais mis à ceux qui m'avait posé
la question et c'est je pense vraiment
n'avoir pas été le seul à le faire mais
en tout état de cause c'est la décision
qui fut prise et je pense que c'est la
bonne décision
encore une fois c'est est-ce que c'est
la bonne ou la moins mauvaise ce qui est
sûr c'est qu'il ne faut pas oublier
quand même qu'il y a des politiques de
l'habitat derrière il y a la question du
rattachement de la vie au logement ou du
logement à la ville etc c'est une vraie
question il faut absolument que ce soit
des politiques de l'habitat parce que le
volet remettre de l'humain c'est ne pas
parler le logement de parler habitat où
vous faites le lien entre l'humain le
territoire et la fonctionnalité donc moi
je suis beaucoup plus à l'aise avec un
ministère de l'Habitat dans
dans sa dénomination même je trouve que
ce serait quelque chose de très
important sur la trésorerie des ménages
et les classes moyennes alors vraiment
l'un n'empêche pas l'autre et peut-être
qu'Emmanuel wargon vous l'avez vous l'a
dit je ne m'en souviens je ne m'en
souviens pas mais en tout cas ce qui est
sûr c'est que nous avions nous étions
battus nous n'avions pas obtenu tout le
des arbitrages en ce sens mais d'autres
ont été obtenus depuis lors pour que ma
prime rénov soit ouverte y compris des
décides les plus élevés parce que oui si
on veut massifier et aller le plus vite
possible il faut accompagner évidemment
la classe moyenne et c'est
incroyablement important et ça n'est pas
parce que j'exprime cette fibre sociale
dans laquelle je crois énormément que
que je ne me focalise pas aussi sur les
classes moyennes bien au contraire et
c'est pour ça que nous avions poussé
pour que des décides
des défis élevés puissent être éligible
ma prime rénov c'est aussi pour cela que
nous avions ouvert ma prime rénov au
bailleur même si contrairement à des
idées reçues il y a des bailleurs qui
peuvent être dans des situations de de
précarité et c'est justement le loyer de
ce
du bien qui leur permet par exemple de
financer le complément de retraite
absolument nécessaire pour pouvoir
vivre convenablement quant aux guichet
unique
encore une fois moi je pense que c'est
probablement une fausse bonne idée ce
guichet unique si je devais la et je
mais c'est là aussi ça fait partie d'une
hygiène collective si je puis dire si
tout le monde arrive à présenter les
mêmes offres
en surpassant le côté c'est c'est la
mienne c'est c'est moi qui c'est moi qui
la super idée c'est moi qui l'ai fait
c'est là vous allez bénéficier de l'aide
uniquement de qui de Lana qui de l'État
qui de la collectivité qui du
département qui du région et vous voyez
par cœur ce que je veux dire parce que
vous vivez tous les jours dans dans le
territoire mais si on arrive à dire
n'importe quel guichet des distribue
l'ensemble des aides en acceptant de
dire d'où vient cette aide ça me paraît
ça me paraît de bonne politique
merci Joël Bigot oui merci
merci de votre intervention c'était
extrêmement intéressant vous avez parlé
notamment du temps long nécessaire et
donc de la vision pour envisager une
énervation énergétique des bâtiments qui
soient performant je rappelle qu'un pays
comme la Suède par exemple mais vous le
savez sans doute ami 20 ans a réalisé
cette opération et pour ce faire vous
nous indiquez que il faudrait sans doute
utiliser des matériaux biosourcés à
l'heure actuelle j'ai rencontré des
professionnels du bâtiment qui
travaillent avec des matériaux
des briques la tuile des gens qui n'ont
pas forcément des produits issus de la
petrochimie et qui nous disent que cette
transition il la soutiennent mais qui va
falloir accompagner ces secteurs
d'activité pour
réussir cette transition énergétique des
bâtiments donc ma question est la
suivante comment envisagez-vous
d'accompagner cette transition et
notamment
vous viviez de la ressource qui
permettrait de d'envisager notamment la
sylviculture qui permettrait d'envisager
une rénovation énergétique des bâtiments
accompli et surtout qu'on puisse
maîtriser parce que la France a quand
même d'immenses ressources et la des
forêts importantes il y a un
savoir-faire mais à l'heure actuelle il
y a des entreprises qui ont besoin
d'être accompagnés pour la transition et
notamment les entreprises dont je vous
parlais je vous remercie de votre
réponse
comme j'ai l'impression que c'est la
dernière question je vous attends
le meilleur le meilleur pour la fin le
meilleur pour la fin
je croyais que c'était la fin
moi je pense que c'est derrière tout ça
il y a une histoire de réconciliation
et la question du bois est un très très
bon exemple
quand j'ai fait mes études de
au zoo et forêt on me disait à l'époque
donc c'était il y a 20 ans on me disait
en France le bois avance
la forêt avance mais le bois recule la
forêt avance mais le bois recule et ce
qui est très vrai c'est-à-dire que les
forêts ne cessaient de croître mais
l'utilisation du bois dans son secteur
industriel les séries etc
reculer ou en tout cas n'avancé pas du
tout la même vitesse
dans le débats sociétales c'est
exactement la même chose c'est à dire
que tout le monde plaide pour avoir de
la construction bois de la rénovation
bois etc etc etc
mais regardez les débats qu'on peut
avoir sur la culture des forêts
qu'ai-je reçu comme remarque quand j'ai
dit une forêt ça se protège mais c'est
se cultive
les mêmes qui parfois font des émissions
de télévision avec du décor tout en bois
parce que c'est une émission sur la
forêt ou sur le bois mais dans
l'émission ne font que critiquer ce que
les forestiers peuvent faire ou ce que
l'industrie peut faire il y a une forme
de cohabitation des contraires dans tout
ça et moi je pense que le temps non
j'ai toujours dit le courage en
politique c'est deux choses c'est
d'affreux affronter le temps et c'est
probablement la chose la plus difficile
et le deuxième point c'est d'affronter
la complexité des choses oui il faut
protéger une forêt il faut la cultiver
oui si on veut faire de la rénovation
avec des matériaux biosourcés et bien il
faut cultiver le chanvre ne tombe pas du
ciel la forêt le bois ne tombe pas du
ciel il faut aller couper des armes faut
se poser la question des bonnes espèces
de la protection etc mais à la fin des
fins sinon qu'est-ce qu'on a on a
exactement ce qui revient dans plein de
cas et ce contre quoi moi j'ai lutté
avec force pendant toutes quelques
années notamment ministère de
l'Agriculture de l'Alimentation c'est
cette fameuse Maxime loin des yeux loin
du cœur et donc on va dire on veut de la
construction bois on veut pas couper nos
arbres et donc on va importer du bois
des pays du Nord qui vont être coupés
avec des mécaniques qui ne sont
absolument pas qui ne seraient
absolument pas accepté dans notre pays
un non sens l'environnement n'a pas de
frontière donc il faut réussir à
affronter cette complexité mais c'est
très complexe parce que ça veut dire bah
oui il faut développer la culture du
bois dans notre pays mais enfin quand
vous dites ça ici on est tous d'accord
ensuite quand vous êtes sur des
parcelles de forêt c'est beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus compliqué
et ça veut dire ça veut pas dire qu'il
ne faut pas améliorer les choses qu'on
fait il y a beaucoup beaucoup de choses
que nous avons fait que nous avons lancé
les assises du bois et de la forêt à
l'époque pour permettre d'avancer dessus
mais c'est très important
affronter le temps affronter la
complexité sans jamais se résigner
aux simplisme c'est très vrai dans les
matériaux
biosourcés il y a à mon avis je
terminerai par là un point qui fait que
ça va beaucoup s'accélérer et je le vois
dans mes nouvelles fonctions aujourd'hui
où je travaille dans dans sur beaucoup
sur les sujets climatiques
aujourd'hui de plus en plus les
constructeurs sont vont devoir faire le
bilan carbone de leur structure et à
partir du moment où on a réussi à
modifier et
sans être technique mais à modifier à
modifier bon en tout cas faire en sorte
que les analyses de cycle de vie soient
prises en compte dans les bilans carbone
des différents projets et bien l'analyse
d'un cycle de fille d'un matériel
biosourcé pourra permettre au bâtiment
d'avoir un bilan carbone peut-être
supérieur à l'analyse du cycle à celui
qui l'aurait eu s'il n'était que du tout
béton et comme tout le monde aujourd'hui
se pose cette question et demain
probablement devra tout publier sur ces
bilan carbone ce sera à mes yeux un
accélérateur j'en suis sûr en tout cas
pas putatif assuré de l'utilisation de
ces matériaux biosourcés
alors pour la dernière
merci monsieur le ministre pour votre
présentation et vous explications
la conversation c'est déroulé de manière
très urbaine donc je vais je vais
peut-être jouer mettre un peu de poil à
gratter dans votre exposé vous avez mis
le social au cœur des politiques
publiques en général et finalement
de la mère non pas des batailles
mais mais des politiques publiques et
notamment donc la transition climatique
et ses différentes déclinaisons
énergétiques révénovation des bâtiments
etc je n'ai pas su voir
en quoi la réforme des aPL que vous avez
conduite avec une dimension sociale
mais certainement que qu'à l'époque vous
n'étiez vous n'étiez pas seul seul
décideur je ne suis certain et par
ailleurs donc est-ce que vous pourriez
nous
nous apporter des explications par
rapport à ça et par ailleurs des des
spécialistes dont je ne suis pas
évidemment de l'économie de l'habitat et
de la construction
considèrent que le
à cette époque là vous étiez en charge
le modèle du logement social a été
déséquilibré
donc ma question est la suivante
qu'en pensez-vous d'abord et et à
posteriori quelle est la part quelle est
la part de ces décisions dans
l'effondrement de la production de
logements social aujourd'hui je vous
remercie
oh mais bon enfin c'est quand même on
est quand même dans le sujet quoi le
sujet là vous avez raison monsieur le
sénateur montoget c'est que la
rénovation non non
sur la c'est que évidemment la les
bailleurs sociaux
sont confrontés à la rénovation des
bâtiments de manière absolument massive
donc
la première des sources de rénovation
des bâtiments des bailleurs sociaux
c'est tout de même l'enru même si c'est
pas la seule je tiens quand même à dire
que la rue conformément un engagement du
Président de la République nous avions
doubler l'enveloppe de leur rue à mon
époque qui depuis a encore été augmenté
sans compter tout le travail
d'accélération parce qu'on sait à quel
point c'est compliqué d'accélérer les
les projets de leur rhume enfin le
ministre du logement actuel ancien
président de lanrupe connaît
parfaitement tous ces tous ces sujets
sur la réforme des appels il y en a deux
différentes il y en a une qui était le 5
euros des appels je crois que j'avais
dit en ces termes c'était une connerie
donc je me permets d'être cavalier
sur sur les 5 euros d'APL je pense que
c'est c'est assez évident pas du tout ce
que je prône ensuite il y a eu une
deuxième réforme des bailleurs sociaux
que connaît très bien Madame la
Présidente puisque elle était au cœur de
la loi Elan
et qui l'avait une complétude entre d'un
côté la RLS de l'autre côté le
regroupement des bailleurs sociaux de
l'autre côté de la vente d'un certain
nombre de logements social
est-ce que est-ce qu'au final cette
réforme dans sa globalité
était nécessaire pertinente
se regroupement s'avère
utile
je serais très très heureux de lire un
rapport du Sénat sur l'efficacité de
cette réforme portée dans la loi élan
très très heureux c'est d'ailleurs le
rôle du Parlement que ces politiques
publiques évidemment moi je pense que
dans le je suis incroyablement attaché
au modèle du logement social je pense
que comme tout modèle c'est important de
pouvoir se poser des questions
d'affronter des discussions qui sont
complexes je me souviens que madame la
Présidente nous avions longuement
discuté par exemple de la vente
qui est un vrai sujet et ça n'est pas
antisocial que de se dire est-ce que
avoir favorisé la vente des logements
sociaux est un élément pertinent
on en avait discuté pendant des heures
et des heures et des heures et
d'ailleurs un débat tout à fait
constructif pour voir qu'est-ce qui
qu'est-ce qu'il fallait faire est-ce que
ça permettait de à la fois de donner un
parcours résidentiel à ceux qui le
souhaitaient
donner des capacités de fonds propres
aux payeurs
permettre
aussi de faire tout cela dans un cadre
qui soit extrêmement
réglementé régulée puisque la loi est
lent prévoyait des capacités
de pour le nouveau propriétaire de de
revendre immédiatement au bailleur si
quelconque difficulté il y avait de
gestion des de la copropriété par le
bailleur directement etc etc donc à
chaque fois trouver des bons points
d'équilibre mais évidemment
ça fait partie des réformes complexes
parce que
l'avenir dira si oui ou non
Japon atteint tous les tous les des
objectifs que nous avions escompté je
suis sûr que le Parlement et le Sénat se
posera la question
derrière tout ça il y a la question de
budgétaire est-ce que les politiques du
logement ont fait l'objet de réduction
budgétaire oui et ça vous le savez vous
l'avez vu chaque année dans les débats
des lois de finance donc oui il y a eu
des réductions budgétaires et ça n'est
pas nouveau que de dire que
c'est d'ailleurs pas du tout propre au
dernier quinquennat je déroulais vu de
pour ceux d'entre vous qui sont là de
depuis plus longtemps que le dernier
quinquennat
vous savez très bien que année après
année il y a toujours eu la question du
soutien budgétaire ou politique de
logement avec parfois des systèmes de
yoyo qui ont été faits et qui renvoient
aux questions que que madame la
Présidente Monsieur rapporteur vous
initialement sur la visibilité la plus
riche annualité
le fait même qui est toutes ces
questions sur les budgets associés aux
politiques du logement je pense qu'en
fait c'est l'introduction même si je
peux me permettre de votre commission
d'enquête pourquoi il y a tout le temps
ce sujet là parce que certains voire
beaucoup considèrent que les politiques
de logement ne sont pas assez efficaces
et quand on considère qu'une politique
n'est pas assez efficace et que la
politique le budget qui est consacré est
un budget qui est très significatif on
se dit bon bah est-ce que on devrait
permettre ces budgets sur d'autres
choses et parfois et parfois il est
compliqué
et je crois que Emmanuel wargon vous
l'avez dit au moment du cite il est
parfois
ou Madame la directrice de cabinet
Nicolas Hulot je ne sais plus et il
était parfois difficile de d'avancer un
argument disant ben voilà
c'était tout le débat qu'on avait sur
les portes et fenêtres
sur l'efficacité énergétique de ces
mesures
et donc oui c'est compliqué je sais
c'est compliqué en tout état de cause
moi je pense que tout cela renvoie à la
pluri annualité et à la lisibilité
typiquement sur les fenêtres moi je
pense que
il lui fallut continuer sur les fenêtres
ou en tout cas réduire beaucoup moins
parce que au-delà de l'efficacité c'est
aussi un signal et que le signal est une
partie de l'efficacité et qu'il faut pas
l'oublier et que c'est peut-être parce
que vous commencez par changer vos
fenêtres que à la fin vous faites la
rénovation extérieure de votre bâtiment
et qu'il ne faut pas de manière bête et
méchante avec des œillères se dire bah
tiens je regarde l'efficacité de tel et
telle manière mais en tout état de cause
pour répondre
et terminer comme ceci je suis sûr que
plus la politique sera efficace moins la
question des yodos budgétaires année
après année ne sera ne sera posée ça
c'est sûr donc soyons efficaces
moi si vous voulez moi je suis moi je
pense que mais je pense qu'il est
c'est alors c'est vraiment pas ici je
suis même gêné de dire ça ici parce que
effectivement quand je vois ce qui se
passe en ce moment sur certains bancs à
l'Assemblée nationale
Montesquieu doit vraiment se retourner
dans sa tombe
ici de laisser et des lois vous l'avez
chevillé au corps il coule dans dans vos
veines mais une loi ça devrait être loi
beaucoup moins une loi ça doit être la
vision ça doit être le sens ça doit pas
forcément être les outils sauf les voies
de finances et ensuite le rôle du
Parlement c'est d'évaluer d'évaluer
d'évaluer et vous devriez faire le sens
et l'évaluation d'ailleurs le sens et
l'évaluation c'est très proche de la
vision du quotidien
mais la loi qui devient la loi bavarde
avec des pizzas et je dis ça en
en ayant conscience que
j'ai
péché également parce que madame la
Présidente elle leur rapporteur de la
loi Elan s'en souvient on peut pas dire
que la loi est lente soit une loi qui ne
soit pas une loi bavarde à certains
égards c'est une voix qui parfois est
très technique
j'ai le sentiment tout état de cause que
voilà le sens et l'évaluation la vision
et le quotidien c'est peut-être ça
appelait à la mémoire de Montesquieu
dans dans cette belle chambre
ma voix
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre
bonne fin de journée